肩幅狭い
肩幅狭い　肩広くなれ
すぐ肩から落ちるから
見れんわ
自分じゃ付けれんわ
これ一人じゃ難しいって
いやむりだわ
むっちゃむりでしょ。あっきたきた
留まった
一人できるもんじゃねえわ
ほらあー肩幅
こんにちは
飲み物の王です。
新発売のペプシゴースト
ミステリーフレーバー
という新しいのが出た
正直何の味かわからん
謎だわ
肩幅狭い
ミステリーフレーバーて書いてあるから
味分からねえわ
とにかく謎だわ
はいというわけで飲み物の世界からやってきた
飲み物の王です。
こんにちは。
俺は今日非常におこている
今日は非常におこているよ
実は今日動画を一本取ったんだよ
あの個人的にはすごい楽しみで
すごいほしかったもので
すごいしたかった動画を撮ったんだけれども
もうねえなんかねえ俺のせいじゃない
本当に今回に関してはね
俺のせいじゃないからね
あの動画を撮ったんですよ
いつも撮ってるこのカメラで
そのとった動画を
さて編集しようかなと思って
パソコンに行って
こうカチカチカチってやったら
データがね
動画のデータが
破損フアイルになってるんですよ
まあそこまではいいよ
そこまでは分かる
データーが破損することもあるからね
sdカードもね
うん
そこまでは俺もね
さすがに鬼ではないから
了解したよ
了解したけども
おかしいなと思って
今使ってるビデオカメラに
sdカードをさしました
そしたら
データが破損しているようです。
復元しますか。みたいな
あっ良かった
復元できるんだな
と思って
はいって押して
復元中です。しばらくお待ちください
よしできるできるって待って
復元完了しましたと
きました
よし
これで今日の動画も編集できる
と思って
パソコンの前にこう言って
肩幅
でパソコンでこう開くとカチカチと
さらに編集しようと
動画のｓｄカードを見ると
ｓｄカードにデータがありません。
バカにしてんのか
おい
おいおいおい
おい肩幅
復元しましたっていったのに
復元されてるどころか
動画のデータが消えてるわけなんすよ
まてよ。おい
俺はもうおこているよ
俺は今日完全におこている
おい
ビデオカメラ
それは復元と言わん
削除という
今日はこんなわけのわからない
動画を撮る予定じゃなかった
ちゃんと動画があるんですけども
データが破損してしまったので今日は
そのことについておこる動画だ
あ飲み物の王です
今後よろしくお願いします
最近ね食べ物の王ていうね
俺とは別にもう一人王がいるんだけども
その王から
なんか僕昔
つえで４そく歩行して歩きますみたいな動画をやって
失敗して
それをちょっとこうさかめにとって
へんなね
悪い人をとっつかまえる棒で
それを５本で歩きます。みたいな動画を出して
お前もやってみろやみたいな
次俺がなんかそうゆう棒でなんかしろやみたいな
あのー
４足歩行ね
杖で４足歩行するやつ僕ガチで怪我したんすよ
あの笑えない方のやつね
急遽で病院送りになって
でもうけつの穴の血が止まらなくなくて
もう一歩で手術で下手したら人工肛門つけて
しばらく病院にいなきゃいけないぐらいのレベルの
大けがをしたので
その勝負には乗らん
ということをちゃんと言わなければいけないなあと思いました。
またね
ほかのきかいで何かできれば
良いと俺は思っている
飲み物の王です。
肩幅
マジねえな
おこているというよりも
萎えているよ。
削除すんなよ。
せめてデータは残しておいてほしかった。
難しいよ。
世の中は本当に難しい。
ローソンのアップルジュース美味しいです。
もう一つちょっとお知らせがあるんですけれども、
はじめしゃちょーっていう
Tシャツがですね、
もうすぐ再販されます。
アマゾンはなんか
はんえいが遅いらしくて
この日の何時に出ます。
ってことは言えないんですけれども
近々再販されるようなので、
良かったらそちらの方もチエックしておいてください。
アマゾンではじめしゃちょーTシャツ再販します。
明日
明日今日か明日中だと思います。
はい、というわけで
飲み物の王でした。
おこているというより、
あきれてる
俺は
また次回の童話
次回の童話とか言っちゃった。
次回の動画でお会いしましょう。
じゃあな！